do you remember when we first met I do
so it was we had a song called don't you
want to stay that we had on there so we
had the song that that I had and my
producer and I were talking about who we
wanted to get to sing him a song and
Kelly was the first person that I
thought of and I'd never met her it was
just a huge fan of her voice and and so
that we had never met until the day we
were in the studio you were recording a
song and it's such a great song I was i
sat there and I had all these notes that
okay we're gonna get her to sing this
part and that part and we went in and
she just started warming up and sing the
song a couple times and after she's
saying I just took my notes and threw
him in the trash I wasn't gonna tell you
I had a note I heard you sing I think
this is gonna be really good do it you
wanted to you did just fine and we also
we performed at the Grammys together we
got to do that song with the grannies
together yeah now what do you remember
about that performance because I have
something I have to own up to yes so
first time it's my first time performing
on the Grammys yeah we're singing this
song they've been a huge hit for us and
and we're singing it and I look over and
Kelly has a tear coming out out of her
ad I'm like man I must be like really
singing this song really well I mean
this is like an emotional thing it's
really hitting her hard you know and as
soon as we come offstage she goes I had
something in my eye the whole time you
see
and so just completely completely wiped
me out no no here's the thing I'm owning
this now I totally lied so I didn't want
you to think I was a freak oh stop no I
totally lied they will tell you right
now I cry like I get all the fields I'm
singing and I was really crying and I
totally lied was like there was
something my allergies there's something
I would like totally lime I was feeling
it I thought it was good perform it but
something flew it around no it did not
I'm telling you you can ask Brandon I
totally lied I literally I always cry
all the time
Blake makes so much fun of me for it but
I just feel all the time all the fields
and I've yeah I get really caught up do
you do that when you're singing never
just get caught up I do that like so
often it's annoying that's why I lied
because I'm weird but anyway I thought
you're weird I know no it was such a
beautiful song it's such a great thing
go to the Grammys well I'll say this a
huge thank you to you because that song
I mean it was on an album we had called
my kind of party which was a huge record
for us but that song in particular you
know that song in particular not only
was a big country hit but it was a big
crossover hit for me which kind of I
think opened it up to it to a lot of new
you know a new audience for me getting
some of the pop audience to kind of be
aware of me so it was that was a huge
song for my career so things well you
know what then I ended up opening up for
him in a stadium showed up and I was
like oh my god I had never played a show
that big a Wrigley Field Chicago I was
like I will open for you anytime brother
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this